ruf nach strengeren corona regeln die
infektionszahlen in deutschland bleiben
hoch der streit um die richtige
strategie wird heftiger wer wird zuerst
geimpft die impfkommission legt ihren
plan vor millionen risikopatienten ärzte
und pfleger haben die höchste priorität
und der bundestrainer schimpft über
seinen arbeitgeber joachim löw will
seinen weg weiter geht und greift die
dfb spitze an
die nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers und in allen hier ist
ihre nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag den sportlichen teil steuert
katja stresow bei deutschland kommt
nicht über den berg so scheint es bayern
wird schärfere corona maßnahmen
verhängen und auch andere bundesländer
denken laut darüber nach denn eine echte
trendwende ist nicht in sicht
der blick auf die gemeldeten positiven
testergebnisse ist auch heute ernüchtert
das robert koch institut verzeichnete
binnen 24 stunden 12 1332 neuinfektionen
das sind 1163 mehr als vor einer woche
mit 146 erreicht die sieben tage des
incident im bundesweiten durchschnitt
einen neuen höchstwert
alle bundesländer gelten jetzt als
risikogebiete und so gibt es neue
forderungen dass die regeln verschärft
werden noch vor weihnachten nicole
diekmann mit den politischen
standpunkten hessens ministerpräsident
bouffier heute mittag in wiesbaden
in normalen zeiten ist dies ein
kongresszentrum jetzt im ausnahmezustand
ein ort der hoffnung hier soll geimpft
werden so schnell wie möglich und so
viel wie möglich
doch bis dahin sieht es noch mal nach
deutlichen verschärfungen aus die zahlen
sind immer noch zu hoch und sie sehen
die insbesondere dort zu hoch wo wir ein
dauerhaft sehr hohes infektionsgeschehen
haben und das sind aus meiner sicht die
bereiche sowie über 200 in grenzen sind
und ich halte für richtig dass wir dort
eine ausgangssperre seien so gut wie
nirgends ist entspannung in sicht einige
landkreise in deutschland überschreiten
inzwischen sogar die inzidenz zahl von
500 in bayern müssen sich die bürger
innen bereits von übermorgen an auf
ausgangs beschränkungen einstellen
mancherorts sogar auf ausgangssperren
schaffen es ja deutlich nach weil die
zahlen einfach nicht ausreichen nur für
die drei weihnachts feiertage gibt es
eine kleine ausnahme auch an silvester
nicht
eine kleine ausnahme für weihnachten das
soll schon drin sein denn triste
feiertage das will die politik den
leuten nicht zumuten
doch die ersten stimmen mahnen dem virus
sind festtage egal
das erzeugt reisetätigkeit die leute
fahren sie besuchen sich gegenseitig und
deswegen glaube ich müssen wir noch mal
schauen wie entwickeln sich die zahlen
und dann noch mal überlegen ob das eine
richtige entscheidung ist weihnachten
gegen null fahren niedersachsen lädt das
für sich ab wir haben auch eine fallende
tendenz in der letzten woche gehabt ich
hoffe dass setzt sich sofort da wo es
gut läuft da geht auch mehr als in
andern bereichen zweieinhalb wochen noch
bis weihnachten eigentlich wollten bund
und länder bis dahin nicht noch mal über
die korona lage beraten
ob es dabei bleibt auch daran wachsen
die zweifel haben wir unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondenten mit dazu
theo koll und am thema die
bundeskanzlerin soll heute gesagt haben
die jetzigen maßnahmen werden uns nicht
durch den winter bringen was wird denn
da jetzt vor weihnachten tatsächlich
noch auf uns zukommen
aus kreisen der ministerpräsidenten
haben wir eben gehört die dinge seien
zwar noch im fluss aber ein weiteres
treffen mit der kanzlerin sei er
wahrscheinlich und das könnte dann ja
nur weitere verschärfungen bedeuten
beziehungsweise eine rücknahme von
angekündigten lockerungen das kanzleramt
wiederum hat intern alle länder
angefragt zu welchen weiteren maßnahmen
sie bereit sind um unter 50
neuinfektionen zu kommen die kanzlerin
ist so wurde mir heute bedeutet nur zu
einem weiteren treffen bereit wenn die
beschlüsse klar über die jetzigen
hinausgehen eine fortschreibung des
shutdown leid werde man auf keinen fall
fortschreiben
jetzt ist eto so ein hin und her
natürlich nicht besonders gut für die
akzeptanz und die vermittelbarkeit
dieser maßnahmen bei den menschen in
deutschland hat sich die politik auch
darüber gedanken gemacht
davon muss man ausgehen das muss ja
eigentlich allen klar sein und trotzdem
scheinen alle länder chefs und chefinnen
anfällig zu sein für ausnahmen dann
jedenfalls wenn die lage in ihrem
eigenen land scheinbar besser ist und
nicht wenige werden dann doch von der
pandemie eingeholt wenn sachsens
ministerpräsident beispielsweise jetzt
sagt man habe das virus unterschätzt
dann ist es natürlich eine erkenntnis
pleite die die weisheit der entscheider
schwer torpediert und damit dann auch
die akzeptanz weiterer maßnahmen sagt
theo koll in berlin
theo vielen dank
insbesondere die sogenannten hot spots
müssen sich auf strengere regeln
einstellen also die regionen die
besonders hohe infektionszahlen melden
und die liegen derzeit
überdurchschnittlich oft in thüringen in
bayern und vor allem in sachsen mit
einer inzidenz von über 200 der
landkreis der innerhalb einer woche die
zweithöchste zahl von neuinfektionen
gemeldet hat ist die sächsische schweiz
die inzidenz hier über 530 fälle je
100.000 einwohner aus pirna berichtet
thomas bärsch kathrin hoffmann musste
ihren hundesalon in pirna schon im
lockdown im märz schließen und nun so
sieht es aus bald wieder
natürlich sieht auch wie die hohen
fallzahlen und doch zeigte sich
verunsichert
ich werde nie etwas nicht richtig finden
soll keine ahnung weil so viel
widersprüchliches in den medien auch im
landkreis liegt die sieben tage
incidents bei über 500 sachsen führt
bundesweit die korona statistik an
der ministerpräsident stimmt das land
auf härtere maßnahmen ein auch als
signal an die die sich bislang den
regeln verweigern
es gibt einen teil der das alles noch
nicht ernst nimmt
denen müssen wir jetzt glaube ich in
aller deutlichkeit zeigen dass es ernst
ist interner treffen wir heute nur
wenige ohne maske doch auch unter ihnen
zeigen sich manche verunsichert warum
aber wiederum sagen die ärzte dass die
maske nicht das nicht bringt standard in
der zeitung drin
also was ist nur gut tatsächlich scheint
sachsen ein problem zu haben mit corona
skeptischen ärzten die als
multiplikatoren auftreten die zuständige
kammer schaut hier genau hin
wir wollen das so weit ist möglich im
einzelfall prüfen und dann wird
entschieden gibt es tatsächlich berufs
rechtsverstöße mutter sind es gar
strafrechtlich relevante dinge und also
zum beispiel nicht sachgerechte
entscheidungen falsch
gutachtenerstellung oder ähnliches dann
machen wir es gibt es auch statt also
eine anzeige zumindest bei der
staatsanwaltschaft und dort ermittlung
einzuleiten
doch es bleibt ein schwieriges tor
kathrin hoppe in ihren hundesalon
rechnet derweil fest damit demnächst
ihren laden wie im märz schließen zu
müssen sie tröstet sich mit der hoffnung
dass das dann auch wenigstens was bringt
und die fallzahlen endlich sinken noch
eine wichtige frage heute wer soll
zuerst gegen korona geimpft werden wenn
der impfstoff zugelassen wird dann wird
es zunächst viel zu wenig davon geben um
alle gleichzeitig versorgen zu können
wie also soll die reihenfolge aussehen
jetzt mal jenseits der problematik
welchen impfstoffes gibt und überhaupt
und was ist der zeitrahmen von all dem
ist
antworten gibt die ständige
impfkommission des robert-koch-instituts
sie hat jetzt ihre empfehlung
veröffentlicht christoph distel hat mir
priorität sehr hoch allein darunter
fallen 8,6 millionen menschen
sie gelten als besonders gefährdet zum
beispiel alle die über 80 sind oder die
in seniorenheim wohnen oder
medizinisches personal mit sehr engen
kontakt zur wird patienten oder alle
pfleger und pflegerinnen von senioren
dann die priorität hoch und das wären
weitere 6,7 millionen menschen alle
zwischen 75 und 80 gehören dazu außerdem
medizinisches personal mit hohem risiko
sich oder andere anzustecken oder demenz
patienten und ihre betreuer drei weitere
gruppen nennt die kommission absteigend
von moderater bis runter zu gering
erhöhter priorität
dazu zählen alle menschen über 60 vor
allem vor erkrankte und deren engste
angehörige aber auch lehrer
erzieherinnen polizei feuerwehr bis hin
zu beschäftigten im einzelhandel
insgesamt sind das fast 37 millionen
menschen und schon deren impfung da dort
viele unbekannte sind in der gleichung
aber das impfen für alle anderen dürfte
wohl frühestens im sommer losgehen
schnelle hilfe das war das versprechen
dass die bundesregierung betrieben
gemacht hat die wegen der korona
beschränkungen schließen mussten
aber die sogenannten november hilfen
lassen auf sich warten bis zu 75 prozent
des umsatzes im vorjahreszeitraum sollen
erstattet werden
mehr als 130.000 unternehmen haben diese
hilfe beantragt jetzt gibt es zwar erste
abschlagszahlungen aber nicht viel mehr
außer der bitte um geduld fabian köhler
berichtet noch ist die küche im
restaurant müller nicht kalt ein paar
außer haus bestellungen werden
vorbereitet 18 mitarbeiter und vier
auszubildende beschäftigt das
familienunternehmen seit dem erneuten
schatten jongliert chefin grit müller
mit den betriebskosten schnell hatte sie
die november hilfen beantragt auf das
geld wartet sie noch immer wir haben
jetzt noch das glück dass die bank mit
spielt also dass wir auf pump leben
quasi erst mal und versuche natürlich
auch von allen unseren lieferanten die
rechnungen zu bezahlen
10.000 euro per sofort abschlag aus dem
hilfspaket der bundesregierung sollen
die müllers bekommen die ausstände bei
ihnen mehr als dreimal soviel sowie die
müllers warten zehntausende unternehmen
auf die gelder stehen mit dem rücken zur
wand
viele betriebe erleben reinste
existenznot und es wird in vielen fällen
auch davon gesprochen dass die anmeldung
einer insolvenz unmittelbar vor der tür
steht die software zur auszahlung sei
noch nicht fertig heißt es aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium kritik kommt von
der opposition
die wirtschaftsminister der bundesländer
hätten schon vor wochen das problem
benannt dass die verwaltungsvereinbarung
und die software nicht zur verfügung
stehen um die november hilfen
auszuzahlen wenn jetzt gesagt wird das
teilweise noch später ausgezahlt wird
und das ist nur abschlagszahlungen geben
kann ist das unverantwortlich vom
herangehen durchhalten vermutlich bis in
den januar heißt es nun für die
gastrobranche freunde haben den müllers
leihweise geld angeboten um über die
runden zu kommen doch nicht jeder hat
solche solvente freunde und so fiel
zunächst zum thema corona in dieser
sendung weder frei noch fair das ist der
kommentar der bundesregierung zur
parlamentswahl in venezuela haben die
haben die sozialisten von präsident
nicolas maduro nach offiziellen angaben
mit 67 prozent der stimmen gewonnen
während maduro von einem klaren sieg der
demokratie spricht prangert der selbst
ernannte interimspräsident 3d wahlbetrug
an
die wahlbeteiligung lag bei nur 31
prozent
der opposition hatten zum boykott
aufgerufen das parlament war die letzte
noch nicht von adoro beherrschte
institutionen des südamerikanischen
landes in armenien gehen seit tagen
tausende menschen auf die straße sie
sind wütend auf ihre regierung
es geht um berg karabach und das
waffenstillstandsabkommen mit
aserbaidschan dorthin aserbaidschan
hingegen ist die freude groß denn das
land kontrolliert inzwischen wieder rund
zwei drittel der umkämpften gebiete die
muster armenien laut vereinbarung
zurückgeben
tausende aserbaidschan wollen bald
wieder nach berg karabach zurückkehren
zum beispiel in die stadt die dann von
dort berichtet jörg brase da drüben
haben wir gewohnt sagt maria mies
mainova saddam war mal reich und schön
bis 1993 damals eroberten armenische
truppen die provinzhauptstadt maryams
ehemann und ihr bruder starben
heute kehrt sie zurück nach über 27
jahren
ich bin glücklich und stolz natürlich
ist hier alles zerstört aber ich bin
wieder zu hause
denn hier habe ich gelebt hier bin ich
aufgewachsen nur die moschee von madame
steht noch hamlet ibrahim oft in den
90ern gegen die arminia gekämpft der
hass auf den feind damals wie heute ist
groß die haben hier drin tiere gehalten
möge gott sie dafür bestrafen in einem
muslimischen gebetsraum haben sie
schweine schafe und kühe gehalten
berg karabach ist unser sagt hamlet er
ist stolz dass einige zonen wieder unter
aserbaidschanische kontrolle kommen und
er weiß dass ein teil des sieges über
armenien auf das konto türkischer
drohnen geht türkische kriegstechnik und
angeblich auch söldner haben diesen
krieg mit entschieden in der kommenden
woche wird der türkische präsident
erdogan nach aserbaidschan com und an
der sieges parade teilnehmen
ein sieg der mit türkischer hilfe
zustande kam und ein weiterer schritt
ist auf dem weg die türkei als wichtige
regionalmacht zu etablieren gebet für
die gefallenen kriegshelden die berge am
horizont gehören zum armenischen teil
berg karabach
nochmal werdet ihr unser land nicht
bekommen rufen sie den feinden zu es
spricht aus ihnen die genugtuung der
sieger und jetzt sein blick auf die
situation beim klimaschutz
umweltorganisationen haben heute ihren
jährlichen index vorgestellt wie
erfolgreich die länder da sind nur 14
länder wurden als gut bewertet hier grün
markiert von den insgesamt 57 ländern
mit dem größten ausstoß an
treibhausgasen
allen voran schweden großbritannien und
dänemark deutschland hat sich leicht
verbessert hier kritisieren die experten
unter anderem den unverändert hohen
ausstoß im bereich verkehr
es gibt handlungen die sich als ikone
erweisen die mehr ausdrücken können als
worte das hat polens präsident andré
duda heute erklärt er meint diese geste
von willy brandt vor genau 50 jahren
warschau das denkmal für die helden des
aufstands im jüdischen ghetto
der kniefall von warschau ging in die
geschichte ein und wurde zum symbol für
die deutsch polnische aussöhnung
der damalige bundeskanzler bekannte sich
zur deutschen kriegsschuld und den
verbrechen des holocaust und bat
gleichzeitig um vergebung
aus warschau natalie steger gemeinsames
erinnern an die wucht dieser geste des
kniefalls von willy brandt einst genau
hier vertreter des polnischen
präsidenten und des bundespräsidenten
steinmeier in einer videobotschaft mit
polnischen untertiteln migrant und
widerstandskämpfer der selbst ohne
schuld war bekannte mit seinem kniefall
deutsche schuld und bat um vergebung
darin lag die größe dieser geste willy
brandt der siebte dezember 1970 brand
reist nach polen um den warschauer
vertrag zu unterschreiben die
bundesrepublik wird die ostgebiete nicht
mehr zurückfordern zu hause hoch
umstritten eine geste wird vom besuch um
die welt gehen vor dem denkmal für den
ghetto aufstand der kniefall
brandt verharrt eine halbe minute lang
spontan erklärt er später konnte dann
lass dich nicht anderes tun als zeichen
zu setzen ich bitte als einer der nun
nicht zu den wildesten am engen etwas
gehört hat um es mal so zu sagen ich
bitte für mein volk umfeld seien
die kommunistische regierung polens
verschweigt in den medien den kniefall
fast komplett es passt ihnen nicht ins
bild vom bösen deutschen als ich meinen
artikel mit diesem bild bei bildern
walter wurde das bild unten
abgeschnitten durch die zensur als eher
abgeschnitten
wir bleiben stünde doch die macht des
bildes ist schließlich größer
vieles aber nicht alles ist seitdem
ausgeräumt polens nationalkonservative
regierung spricht bis heute die frage
nach deutschen reparationszahlungen für
den zweiten weltkrieg
[Musik]
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung an
diesem montag bei katja teamsport genau
lange wurde nur über ihn gesprochen
heute meldete sich fußball bundestrainer
joachim löw erstmals selbst zu wort und
sprach offen über frust und enttäuschung
und dabei meinte er nicht nur die 0 6
niederlage vor knapp drei wochen gegen
spanien
das vertrauliche details aus einer
präsidiumssitzung nach außen getragen
wurden das schien für löw fast wichtiger
als fußballspezifisches da herrscht
vielleicht auch explosionsgefahr bei mir
wenn die dinge dann vielleicht so nach
außen gehen die nicht danach außen
gehören abgetaucht nach dem 0 6 gegen
spanien abgenutzt nach 14 jahren als
bundestrainer ohne feuer kein kämpfer
mehr diesen vorwürfen widerspricht er
energisch und trainer kämpft immer an
verschiedenen freundin kämpft immer um
verbesserungen kämpft gegen rückschläge
zu wenige gemeinsame trainingseinheiten
im corona ja das trifft aber auch auf
andere zu dennoch hätten die spieler
sein vertrauen seit ich muss sagen
befindet sich diese junge mannschaft
wenn man mal von dem spanien spiel ist
ab sieht auf einem guten weg von dem wir
überzeugt
die ausgemusterten boateng hummels und
müller als nothelfer unwahrscheinlich
aber nicht ausgeschlossen erst nach der
em werde bilanz gezogen danach über
seine position das sei normal für einen
trainer so löw 2022 findet in katar die
nächste fußball-wm statt mit oder ohne
löw wird man sehen
deutschland muss sich aber erst noch
qualifizieren und gerade eben wurden in
zürich die gegner ausgelost und das sind
in gruppe j
rumänien island nord mazedonien armenien
und liechtenstein klingt machbar
die deutsche fußball liga dfl hat heute
beschlossen die einnahmen aus den
fernsehgeldern neu zu verteilen
dadurch will man den profivereinen unter
anderem helfen wirtschaftlich besser
durch die korona pandemie zu kommen
lange sehr lange haben sie diskutiert
und gestritten im dfb präsidium über den
neuen verteilungsschlüssel der tv gelder
vor allem auch weil wie christian
seifert einräumen muss die zeiten sehr
schwer
einschließlich der letzten saison wird
der profifußball zwischen märz 2020 und
sommer 2022 voraussichtlich etwa zwei
milliarden euro umsatz verlieren
daher setzt die dfl jetzt auf einen
zweistufenplan zwei jahre lang primär
auf wirtschaftliche stabilität und mehr
gleichverteilung anschließend wieder auf
den leistungsgedanken also etwas mehr
geld für die kleinen und weniger für die
großen wie bayern münchen doch keine
extreme neuverteilung eine spreizung
zwischen bayern und bielefeld zu
reduzieren indem man bayern fünf
millionen weniger gibt und bielefeld 5
millionen mehr macht aber die
meisterschaft nicht spannend kleinere
vereine wie mainz 05 sehen das anders
haben auf größere solidarität gehofft
wir hätten uns insgesamt sicherlich
gewünscht dass die spreizung gerade
zwischen topclubs und kleineren klubs
noch deutlich stärker reduziert wird
neuer schlüssel alter streit die dfl
aber baut er auf sicherheit als auf
radikale lösungen kroner zeiten
vielleicht auch verständlich diese
spreizung herzlichen dank hat ja dann
schauen wir noch aufs wetter auf der
südseite der alpen gibt es auch weiter
viel regen und schnee viel zu viel regen
und schnee bei uns bleibt das wetter wie
es ist ist anthony mit allen details
gleich dann empfehle ich ihnen das heute
schon mal mit der kollegin marietta
slomka 21.45 wir sehen uns gerne morgen
wieder um 19 uhr
für heute danke dass sie dabei waren und
ihnen allen einen sehr angenehmen
untergraben
[Musik]
ein schön kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter zu den großen schneemassen in
der schweiz und in österreich kommt nun
noch mehr schnee dazu ein tief was von
der biscaya in richtung mittelmeer zieht
lenkt hier noch mal feuchte luftmassen
richtungen alpensüdseite und hier kann
noch mal gut ein meter neuschnee
dazukommen
bei uns in deutschland bleibt es
größtenteils trocken in der nacht bildet
sich nebel hauptsächlich entlang der
gewässer und nach süden kann es sogar
rutschig werden bei temperaturen von
minus 1 bis minus 6 grad hier also
leichter bis mäßiger frost deutlich
milder richtung neiße bei plus fünf grad
morgen am nordrand der mittelgebirge da
lockt hat es auf und die sonne kommt
hervor oder auch im südosten an sonst
nach norden viele wolken und auch im
südwesten kann mal die sonne raus
blinzeln aber meistens bleibt es dicht
die temperaturen steigen auf null grad
an den alpen und sieben bis acht grad
nach osten dort ist es wieder am
mildesten
wir schauen auf die nächsten tage am
mittwoch gibt es im süden regen und
schnee und im norden auch etwas regen
dazwischen bleibt es trocken bei 0 bis 7
grad ab donnerstag wird es etwas kälter
damit ein schöner abend